officials believe russian hackers are
behind another major campaign against
u.s government agencies
non-governmental organizations and think
tanks
state department correspondent rich
edson tells us tonight experts believe
it's the same group
responsible for a previous high-profile
attack
russian hackers have hit the u.s
government again
microsoft says the same russian
government-backed cyber operatives
responsible for last year's solar winds
hack infiltrated an email system at the
state department's development agency
and targeted quote government agencies
think tanks consultants
and non-governmental organizations
approximately 3
000 email accounts at more than 150
different organizations
all this less than three weeks ahead of
president biden's summit with russian
president vladimir putin
the ransomware attack by criminal
hackers
earlier this month well that was a
warning shot
so we must defend our nation against
these threats some in congress say the
administration needs to respond to this
latest attack
house intelligence committee chairman
adam schiff says quote russia remains
undeterred despite sanctions following
the solar winds attack
those sanctions gave the administration
flexibility to tighten the economic
screws further if necessary
it now appears necessary microsoft says
the hackers
accessed the u.s agency for
international development's marketing
service
then they used it to send legitimate
looking emails like this
to thousands of accounts clicking on the
link in the email
gives the cyber spys access to computer
systems
these emails went out as recently as
this week
and at least a quarter of the targeted
organizations work in international
development
humanitarian aid and human rights biden
has promised to get tough on russia
republicans have recently criticized the
president for even agreeing to a summit
with the russian president
and for the administration refusing
sanctions on the company building the
nordstrom 2 pipeline
the white house says despite the hack
there are no changes to the biden putin
summit
scheduled for june 16th in switzerland
brent
we'll be there rich edson live the state
department rich thanks hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else